and welcome everyone
the topic we're going to cover today is
very important as we all know growing
company revenues
is a key thing right now and starting
new businesses in established companies
is especially challenging so we're going
to cover
three things the
first is i'll just spend a little bit of
time talking about the
key aspects of starting something
entrepreneurial
and then ricardo will do a deep dive on
the leadership and entrepreneurial
issues
involved in starting new businesses and
then at the end we'll try and bring it
together
uh with the aspects of established
companies and and the entrepreneurial
issues so of course there's a caveat
and that's why we're here
which is um
that the real challenge is getting
things
to work well in established companies
where you have these entrepreneurial
ideas
so there are significant advantages to
working in an established company but
the challenge and again this is why
we're here today
is how to combine the aspects of of each
of those
so let me start with um the
aspects of just a few things about
entrepreneurship
and starting with new ideas
so we very much believe that it makes
sense to actually think about what
you're going to do before you just leap
in
now don't get me wrong i'm not talking
about putting a business plan together
in a room
with the door locked very much you have
to go out and talk to people and
interact
but the reason to spend the time doing
that before you invest a lot of effort
and resources is basically convince
yourself that this is worth doing
and also figure out what it is you're
actually going to need to develop your
product or service
and you're going to have to get money
from somewhere so in an established
company that may
be in front of a committee it may be
through a budgeting process or it may be
through some outside investors but you
need to be able to explain to them
why they should give you money and then
also you're going to need other people
to help you out and so you need to
explain to them
why they might might join you so
basically if you're going to start a new
business you need two things
a good idea and a business model to go
along with it
so in terms of the idea you typically
have a product or service
you need to figure out who the customers
are and this is a key aspect of
actually getting out of your office and
doing things is figuring out that what
you think
is the need for your product or service
that the customers really agree with you
and
it's really something they're willing to
pay for and then you need to figure out
whether or not there's more than just
one person
who might actually do that and
ultimately if you're going to be
successful from a business perspective
you need to have a business model and
it's just a fancy word for figuring out
how you're going to make money doing
what you're doing and in terms of
innovating it really can be
innovation in all or just some of these
so there's many companies that have
innovated in terms of the business model
and and have revolutionized or disrupted
a market
that way
so in terms of um
remembering that it's the entrepreneur
one of the things that's different from
an entrepreneurial point of view
is you really have to take
responsibility for all these things to
really make things happen
so your your job responsibilities are
very broad in that sense
so just a minute on engineering and
science-based businesses both ricardo
and i have worked in
industries that have a strong
engineering and science basis
and one of the challenges here is that
it tends to take a long time and a lot
of money to actually show that something
will work and
i know that most of you are familiar
with this based on the companies that
you
work at and the things you've done so
the need may be obvious but
especially if you're starting with a
technical solution it's important to go
and confirm with customers
that the need is really there
prototyping
you typically can't just do things with
post-it notes that you actually have to
use some fairly expensive equipment and
staff to actually do your prototyping
similarly you typically can't just jump
to commercial production that you need
to do some one or more pilot scales
along the way
oftentimes the regulators who want to
see that you can actually make things on
a commercial scale on a regular
you know consistent basis intellectual
property is often important in these
types of
companies and then also you need a wide
range of technical disciplines to
actually make things work
and finally even if you work in a
company where you have the resources to
go right from the raw materials to the
commercial product
oftentimes you still need partnerships
to actually change a market or access
markets or you may need a special
supplier to provide part of what you
need for your product or service
so a question ricardo and i guess get
asked a lot
is entrepreneurship and established
companies possible
and our answer is a resounding yes
and as good engineers and scientists we
have data to support this
the technology review which is the
magazine published by mit
they have a list of 50 disruptive
companies they put together each year
and the
the list for 2013 just came out recently
and over a third of them were
established companies so companies that
are
around 20 years or more since they were
founded
and in fact something that really
surprised me over 10 of the companies
were over 100 years old and you can see
those 10
those 10 listed here so the notion that
just because you're an established
company you can't be innovative you
can't come up with new things
truly is is not true
so i'm going to turn it over to ricardo
now and he's going to do our deep dive
on leadership and entrepreneurship
issues
thank you howie i'm glad to have a
chance
to talk to you i'd like to take the next
step here
and go into some of the issues of
leadership and entrepreneurship which
i'm sure you're interested in
and which are relevant to our important
topic right now
one thing to emphasize that
no matter whether you are a small
company or a large company
no matter whether you are a startup or
an established company
a good leader is a good leader the thing
that differentiates a leader
from an entrepreneur or makes a leader
an entrepreneur
are two things the nature of the
involvement
which is deeply personal and the
intensity of the commitment
which is total and these are two themes
that i'll be talking about
uh in the next few slides and you'll see
how they shape
the uh the differentiation between
a leader and an entrepreneurial leader
and to do that i'm going to
touch on three key issues
first the difference between leadership
and management
second the nature of the entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial commitment itself and
third
the role of the entrepreneur in the face
of uncertainty
let me start with the first one
difference between leadership and
management
and what i'm doing here is just going to
be to summarize
a very good article which i recommend by
the way i believe you're going to get a
pdf file of all these slides
in after the presentation and so you can
see some of these references
and what i have done is i have captured
the difference between leadership and
management i shouldn't say the
difference the
characteristics of leader
and manager in four key
areas and i'm going to run through them
fairly quickly but you'll see how
at least to me they were very
enlightening in understanding
the two elements so first of all
when a leader points a manager plans
when a leader aligns a manager organizes
when a leader inspires a manager problem
solves
when a leader produces change a manager
produces predictability so just
look at these four pairs
for a minute as either points a manager
plans a lead alliance a manager
organizes a leader inspires a manager
problem solves
a leader produces change a manager
produces predictability
and this doesn't mean really that
they're necessarily different people
it's the leader in you
who does the left it's the manner and
you manager in you
who does the right again i refer you to
the
to the article by carter i'm going to
run very quickly through these just to
give you a little
flavor of what we're talking about but i
recommend you go into the article which
goes into it in much more detail
so dealing first with leader points and
manager plans
a leader basically defines a vision and
a direction
while the manager is tasked with
establishing
budgets and the the activities that are
needed
with respect to aligning and organizing
the leader articulates
and engages in the conversation while
the manager identifies the needed skills
and staff with respect to inspiring and
problem solving
the leader motivates creates a culture
whereas the manager foresees and
addresses hurdles
and finally in the produce change versus
produced predictability
the leader is really tasked with
expanding
the horizons with with with developing
ambitious
goals whereas the manager assures that
these goals can be reached
now these are very different strengths
they are very different inclinations
the key question is how can we boo
both this becomes a particularly
important question
in a situation where you are leading and
managing
and limited resources which as you know
is really
a key characteristic of a small
entrepreneurial
startup but we are proposing is also
what you
if you want to be an entrepreneurial
leader and an established corporation
need to face
so let me run through a few of the
elements of this
first of all as is obvious in an
entrepreneurial mode
you wear both hats
what is important is that you understand
your own propensity to management
or to leadership and to act accordingly
you have to sense when it is time to
lead and when it is time to manage
and you have to behave accordingly at
the right time
this is perhaps one of the biggest
challenges
especially uh for an entrepreneur that
starts a company
is to judge when you need to let others
manage while
you lead and when you have to step in
and
act now none of us is perfect and so
if in fact we need management bolstering
they're very good training programs and
i'm sure many of your companies have
them things like time management
organizational skills
if your challenge is on the leadership
side if you need to sharpen your
leadership
skills the recommendation that howie and
i have and i'm sure this is no surprise
to you
get a good coach and mentor now
you may find one within your own
organization it is
often useful to find mentors and coaches
in other organizations and the last
thing i want to just bring up which is
something that has
haunted me over my 30 years of uh
of presumably success but it took me
it's i still haven't learned when hiring
to appreciate a good manager obviously
but do not confuse it with good leaders
and i have made a number of mistakes
where i saw
fantastic resumes and didn't really
appreciate fully that those
described good managers but didn't
necessarily lead
to good leaders again i recommend that
you go through the article it's
very worthwhile let me turn to a second
item the nature of the entrepreneurial
commitment
how we showed you a slide earlier where
he mentioned that the key characteristic
of the entrepreneur
is the degree of the involvement
of the individual and the intensity of
the commitment
the key is that for the entrepreneur
it's all about a total emotional
engagement with an idea a concept or an
innovation
and i emphasize innovation because in a
more established companies
that is where the entrepreneurial
intensity
will really come once this emotional
engagement
catches okay the entrepreneur is on a
mission
which in fact becomes all consuming
and as a matter of fact nothing
will get in the way of the pursuit of
the mission
in effect what we're talking about is
that the emotional engagement which we
talked about at the top of this slide
is total now such an emotional
engagement has
positives and has challenges
let me talk first about the positive
first of all
and this is obvious your passion feeds
your energy
you often talk about how the
passionate entrepreneur and within a
larger organization
i used to be in one too the passion for
the idea for the innovation creates an
enormous amount of energy
that really is expressed in an
enthusiasm
that that is contagious which then
enables you to attract the best
another very important characteristic of
this
total emotional engagement of an
entrepreneur
is that obstacles become challenges
not roadblocks okay they become
opportunities
for testing the limits and for finding
how to overcome it
in fact i like to characterize the whole
thing in one phrase
which applies whether you are in a small
organization or a large one
for the entrepreneurial leader there is
no
problem related to your mission
that is not your problem from the dirt
in the hallway to the issues of how to
get a multi-million dollar contract
signed
no problem related to this mission is
not
your problem okay
on the negative side at least
that's have been my experience okay the
um emotional engagement
is so overriding that
i have felt and i others and other
entrepreneurs have
to be involved in everything okay
and the coming with that is a sense
often of impatience
i can do it faster myself now sometimes
this comes with a sense of i can do it
better myself
and you'll see that's very dangerous
because what that results in
is that in fact we do not leverage our
team
okay and it's not done because
of not recognizing the power of the team
members
but almost blindly we just charge ahead
and sometimes we do not
draw on our team's skills
and of course something that i alert you
to
in the in a larger corporation that if
in fact you are
so engaged in your mission sometimes you
lose sight that in a larger operation
there is a
organizational structure and there has
to be a certain recognition of the value
and importance and respect
of the people who you report to and
overall you know what you're doing is
you have a sense of possessiveness which
then translates into a strong need for
control
now there are consequences of control we
won't go i won't go into these
uh very in very in great detail but
there are some of the things that
howie and i talk about in our course at
stanford in the fall
first of all it limits your horizon
and we talk about it in our course in
terms of
constraining or limiting your
ability to expand your frame of
reference
the control kind of shrinks you it also
then
ends up blocking the the leader's
ability
to see options which especially in a
smaller company
limits the leader's preparedness to deal
with the unexpected
and something again that i've had a
challenge with
is that it has pushed me often to act
prematurely which of course is not only
it's not only bad for leadership but it
is bad
for uh the success of of an operation
i'd like to turn to the third issue the
role
of a leader in the face of uncertainty
and i'll touch on this just briefly
it's discussed more in several chapters
in my little book that michelle
mentioned
letters to a young entrepreneur and
the concept here comes from the fact
that each of us
has our we have our own risk profile our
own
risk affinity okay
and to me one of the key roles of the
leader
is what i express as absorbing
uncertainty
the leader absorbs uncertainty in order
to
release his or her team members
to do their best now many of you are
involved in highly technical
uh companies where the success
is uh is pushing the limits of
technology
and you relate to the fact that when you
have a very talented
scientist or engineer working for you
that individual
is extremely comfortable pushing the
limits
of risk in their domain of expertise
happen
i've had many reporting to me
but whereas their their risk profile is
very
aggressive in the area of their
expertise when it comes to thinking how
am i going to finance the project or how
am i going to
have my company survive their
um their uncertainty starts coming in
and it tends to block their ability to
do
what their best the way i imagine
this is that when i engage as a leader
engage somebody to join me and join my
team
and tell them to become one of
our become part of our effort and our
dream
i take a trust pack-up from that
individual
it's not a written contract it's really
an eye-to-eye
understanding and as i take this trust
packet and put it in my backpack
i establish a covenant with that
individual
it's really basically a promise
that if you do your best trust me
i will do my absolute best to lead us to
the success
of our venture now the consequence of
this
as you grow in responsibility
and the size of your company grows is
the backpack
gets quite heavy okay and the journey
for the leader
becomes very lonely and it's a
fascinating and important topic that we
do
touch on in our class in the fall of how
does the leader
the top leader cope with this loneliness
and this feeling of weight
of the responsibility finally i'd like
to start the con the topic of
uh what is obviously of interest to you
and the topic of this conversation
and that is to touch on some of the
items that deal with
what are the challenges opportunities in
established companies to become more
entrepreneurial
and some suggestions on how to approach
them
okay i want to talk about two edges and
how we started off by saying
uh when he when he provided the caveat
he said okay an entrepreneur and a small
startup company has certain advantages
corporations more established companies
have advantages too and the key is how
to
how to combine the two so let me talk a
little bit about
what we're calling the entrepreneurial
edge
first in an entrepreneurial mindset
the individual needs to feel and feels
fully
empowered okay which means that
accountability
his or her accountability encompasses
the entire scope of the venture from the
innovation
to the actual final commercial success
okay and so in effect
this is important because under
circumstances of tight resources
these tight resources for the
entrepreneur tend to concentrate the
mind
and focus the entrepreneurial effort and
under those circumstances
failure is not an option it is a
possibility
and in fact the possibility for failure
actually tests persistence
tests endurance tests what i said
earlier
about looking at stumbling blocks as
challenges and opportunities rather than
roadblocks
and it tests our ability to push the
limits
and finally in an entrepreneurial
smaller environment
we do have multiple methods
for reward that in the case of a small
company
include company ownership
they're not necessarily pivotal
to create an entrepreneurial attitude
and i mentioned this specifically
because of course in a larger company
like the ones that you are part of that
becomes a little more complicated
but it is an issue to think about and
we'll touch on that at the end
so on the flip side what is the
established company's edge
well first of all clearly your
infrastructure
human resource accounting legal things
that as a small
company we struggle we don't have enough
money
we don't have enough established
presence to attract the right
strengths we struggle with the fact that
we don't have the ability to easily tap
this infrastructure well an established
company has that
and that's very very useful and it's a
tremendous edge
in the innovative process the second of
course is resources both technical
expertise
analytical equipment just the the total
scale
of a resource of an established company
is very
a very powerful component of of success
which comes about also with scale up
muscle and commercial reach
and obviously the influence with policy
makers and regulators
the other thing that an established
company has the luxury of is to have a
long-term mindset
and so this is a this is an ability then
to see
beyond just tomorrow
okay so um the the key
way of grasping this is if we look at
some of the challenges that as an
established company you have to be more
entrepreneur
entrepreneurial and i'm going to split
it into
corporate challenges and personal
challenges
on the corporate side and how we
mentioned that
in his uh in his first part where he
talked about
the need for the entrepreneur to look at
all the stages
of the life cycle of an innovation or
development
the essential necessity for the
entrepreneur to get
close to the customer to test the idea
of viability
that is not always easy in a
more established larger corporation and
of course
uh the the equivalent
issue is to gain enough autonomy
by the entrepreneurial individual
to test an idea and pursue pursue it if
it's good
especially because of some of the
complexities of larger organizational
structures
and of course part of that is the
finesse
and skill needed if you are in a larger
company
to attract cross-functional buy-in
and to get the necessary and full
resources and support and of course
also the fact that you are often
in order to embody your innovation
you need to find new business models
and the key question is uh
really in effect and this is really key
can
a new initiative compete with the bread
and butter projects
in an established company okay these are
some of the corporate challenges now let
us turn to the
what i call the more personal challenges
that
as you think about entrepreneurship in a
larger company you
need to be aware of first of all by
definition
the entrepreneur is starting small and
the question is
can you as a current or prospective
entrepreneur
step into starting small second
and connected with with starting small
is it is a little more difficult to get
noted
in your organization i've been in a
large organization and part of the
the challenge of of of of
especially younger people in a larger
company is
you want to get engaged you want to get
noted
will you be noted can you live with that
challenge of being noted
and with in the context of starting
small and
the challenge of being noted can you
take total ownership
okay and related to what i said earlier
can you overcome the established
corporate operational ballast okay
which will require for you as the
entrepreneur
to put everything on the line while
within the
umbrella of an established company
in fact the reason i
left a large corporation to start a
smaller
company was because although i felt the
security of the larger
umbrella over me it it
inhibited me to feel that i could put
everything on the line
so that's an an important question that
you need to ask yourself
personally internally if you are
pushing the entrepreneurial boundaries
if you will within a large company
and then of course the question of can
you manage
uncertainty and the fear of failure
which in a larger corporation has
different
implications than in a smaller company
so bottom line looking at all of this
what we're really asking
is if you want to be an entrepreneur in
effect
do you feel free within the established
corporation
to fly okay with that i'm going to turn
the uh the podium back to how we
took for some final thoughts
um thank you ricardo and
just in terms of sort of wrapping up the
things that we've we've
touched on today within an established
company it really really helps to have
top leadership buy-in so it provides
sort of that air cover you need to do
the things you're
you're um you're looking to do because
as ricardo mentioned you have to
sort of break a lot of the rules to move
things along
and then and and part of the reason you
need that top leadership support is that
you need to get those resources across
all those range of functional areas
within your company in order to
to ultimately bring your new product or
idea to market
and then as ricardo mentioned just the
reward systems could be more complicated
within a larger company and
uh you know it's ultimately not about
career advancement it's about really
being passionate
for what you're what you're working on
and the way i think about this
is that typically in larger companies
there's a job description that you've
been given
and you can sit and look at your job
description and say okay
is this thing that needs to be done
within my job description and if it's
not you don't do it
if you're passionate about getting
something to happen
you don't care about the job description
you just figure out what is it i need to
do
and you find a way to make it happen
and that can be the challenge in the
larger companies because not every
a lot of people may just be looking at
their job descriptions and wondering why
you're coming and trying to
to help them get something done
so then it's report important to
remember as ricardo said is that the
leadership qualities are the same
so it doesn't matter whether you're in a
larger company or a smaller startup
those those challenges about leadership
versus managing
you need those in either setting but
what also makes you the entrepreneur
it's really the
involvement it's really personal and
it's very
the intensity is very high and just the
the
you know example of that is as
very senior in a very senior roles in
larger companies as well as in my roles
in startups
oftentimes i was driving something to
the fedex office that was nearby because
it wasn't done by three o'clock when the
pickup was and you had to get it to the
fedex office by five o'clock
to get something sent to somebody to
move things along
and i didn't care if i was the president
of the company or not
i was willing to to take the challenge
you know take that package to fedex and
get it done
it's wonderful to to have some of these
questions and uh
so one question was asked if you are a
senior executive how do you foster the
entrepreneurial spirit on a corporation
and uh this is related to the question
another question which larger no how do
you deal with management
in an organization that stifles your
ideas if the idea is not what your
management likes
then it is no good you know all of these
are questions
that um that relate to
to the to the core issue really the
attitude of the top of the organization
is key to establish an entrepreneurial
sense and what needs to happen is
the top man top executives need to
feel that they can it's part of what i
said earlier that the top leader needs
to
take on a ownership or take on
uncertainty but then release
his or her people to do their best they
need to
also release them to do the
entrepreneurial thing
so the key is that if you have a
management that is too concerned with
their own points of view or their own
narrow path which may have been very
successful in the company and maybe the
bread and butter
what needs to happen is the company
needs to find
senior executives who are comfortable
allowing
entrepreneurial people to jump in and do
what
they do best and so in a sense
it's not just finding the
entrepreneurial individuals in your
organization
it's making sure that the top leadership
buys into the entrepreneurial concept
and that the people who they are trying
to
give this this entrepreneurial
capability
feel supported by that top leadership
okay i'm all right i'll just another
question there's a question about
many of you are from developing
economies or emerging economies and
the question was about needing ethics in
those
types of environments but i'll address
that a little bit a little bit more
broadly
one thing that's very interesting in
emerging economies is that
but more and more people are realizing
it there's incredible opportunity for
innovation
oftentimes a key issue is the price of a
product or
service and it used to be the
traditionally
larger companies would just bring a
product from an established economy
and lower the price or be an older model
but more and more what people are
finding is if you actually go and
investigate the need and talk to your
potential customers in an emerging
emerging economy you can actually
develop a product at a very good price
point
very innovative and now more and more
those products are actually
then being taken to established
economies
as as new innovative products as well
and
specifically about ethics bottom line
ethics is really a personal issue
and there are many examples where people
have
essentially you know just said no and
even though there may not be the strong
ethics
culture within the country that they're
working in is that they can set their
own standards
and also they can there are cases where
people have
brought advisors into their company from
places like the world bank for example
um so from external to the to the
country to help
create a new uh a new culture of uh you
know higher
ethical standards
yeah i'm i'm catching i mean i'm trying
to as you can see i'm trying to read
some of the many questions and uh some
are interesting
uh here is uh here's one that uh
um that i'll answer very quickly it asks
should employees in a relatively small
startup expect transparency
in the upper management in the upper
management
the answer is whether you are a small
company or a large company
that's part of the whole concept if
there is no transparency there is no
trust if there is no trust you're not
going to become entrepreneurial period
and the only reason i would say the few
times that howie and i have succeeded in
our entrepreneurial endeavors
is because the top the the team people
believed us and the only way to believe
us is if they believe we are genuine
this is a human one-to-one type thing
okay has nothing to do with with a turf
or anything else
if they don't believe you you failed
from the beginning
in order to believe you you have to be
open and so that's
uh that triggers a lot of thoughts but
there is another
i'll just add to that one of the
startups i worked at earlier in my
career
um the ceo for those of you who are old
enough to remember bill clinton
you know bill clinton was the master of
half truth right you know
i did not write the the classic i did
not inhale right
and the the ceo in this company was
was very much like that he wouldn't lie
to you but he wouldn't tell you the
complete truth and it just ultimately
became very frustrating so
uh the openness is very important let me
just touch on this other this one
uh quickly um ricardo while you're where
you have another others
there's a question about how do you feel
about startups who employees are
distributed geographically around the
country
and um especially with modern
communications like we're using today
it's much easier to do the company that
michelle mentioned where i was
interim president ceo pearl therapeutics
that we recently sold
we actually had employees in silicon
valley we had employees in new jersey we
had employees in north carolina and
there were only about 50 people
in the company we basically had people
scattered around because that's where
the expertise was that we needed
and rather than people didn't want to
move but we knew we needed their
expertise
and so you just have to um if they are
on the side of more communication rather
than less so we had twice weekly senior
leadership teleconferences we made a
point of once a quarter making sure the
senior
staff all got together so you have to
work hard at managing but you definitely
definitely can do it yeah to figure back
on that in
a case when we finally uh succeeded
we had a couple thousand people and we
had operations in many parts of this
country
and the bottom line of how he says is
multiple communication but also physical
presence
i mean you just got to be there that's
the that's the burden of uh
and the excitement of leading a larger
company
i see a question here that is
it's very interesting it says sometimes
entrepreneurship
within a large company is needed in
times of distress and difficulties for
the company
when it is also more difficult to
persuade the management to take the risk
of an innovative idea
that's uh that's food for thought that's
food for thought and
unfortunately what i would say is it
depends on who
is who is leading the charge
and hopefully the top executive of the
company
will recognize that innovation is
the path to getting out of a difficult
situation
if the top of the company does not
recognize that
then i would say i predict it's not
going to work
because again part of the whole concept
of being entrepreneurial in an
established company
is the comfort of the entrepreneur that
the top of the company believes in me
if the comfort isn't there then you are
draining that very energy that you're
trying to tap in the innovative uh
process
a question i'll just it's a specific
question about starting a company in
nigeria
and um ex and what types of
methodologies
methodologies to use such as lean
startups six sigma et cetera
it's specifically about nigeria but it's
really a question that's
that's general and this comes back to
um the point about not sitting in an
office with a door locked
putting together a 100-page business
plan and really the key thing in all
these
all these approaches is getting out and
talking to people
and as much as possible prototyping and
testing
your idea with real customers as early
as possible
you can also something we encourage um
in the entrepreneurship classes
i teach here at stanford is to also you
can learn a lot from industry experts
um as well especially early on to sort
of get a lay of the land but
nothing ultimately substitutes for
getting out and talking to customers
and and trying something with them and
seeing how they respond to it
one last question michelle uh here's a
question interesting in the case of
acquisitions
how does the company being acquired
maintain their entrepreneurial culture
in your experience with them as a
smaller company's culture
has the smaller companies cultural
innovation survive
very good question and
i have had experience both being on the
buying side
and being on the on the bot side so to
speak
and i would say again it's a function of
how
there are two complications here when
you are acquired
you have to become part of one company
you cannot have separate companies so
you cannot continue to have your
your identity of your innovation within
a larger company that just creates major
problems
on the other hand you do want to give
the acquired company the sense that they
have an important
role to play and i would say and how you
you may have more experience on that
that it is important that the
the entrepreneurial leadership of the
smaller company if they
can transition into becoming
important leadership of the larger
company
then you have an optimum because
without continuing to separate the two
so you have to have merger but if the if
the entrepreneurial leader is really
accepted within the larger company as
part of the future
of the combined companies then there's a
good chance actually the larger company
will
will will harness the benefits of the
innovative
effort one or two specific examples on
that is
um the in the in the life sciences area
the
probably the best example was when
hoffman laroche bought genentech
and um at this point now
hoffman roaches actually shut down most
of their research in their traditional
location in new jersey
and really rely on genentech
for their for their core research and a
lot of the senior managers
not all of them but a lot of the senior
managers at genentech ultimately took on
broader roles within
within hoffman roach so for me it
ultimately comes
it comes back to the issue of leadership
and um especially in the acquiring
company do
do the leader is there the leadership to
really figure out how to leverage
uh that entrepreneurial spirit and try
and maintain it and really infect the
rest of the company with it there
good okay thank you
you